[Música]
comenzamos 5 minutos con un espacio de
France 24 con entrevistas breves a
expertos en diversas temáticas que
ocupan un lugar central en la agenda
global nos acompaña como ya es habitual
el doctor Óscar Franco epidemiólogo y
director del Instituto de Medicina
social y preventiva de la Universidad de
Berna también académico de Harvard y de
la universidad Erasmo de rotterdam
asesor científico de France 24 doctor
Gracias por estar con nosotros y
comienzo el estrés que ha generado vivir
en medio de una pandemia ha afectado el
funcionamiento normal de algunos cuerpos
hoy vamos a hablar de esas afectaciones
específicamente en las mujeres Cómo se
ha trastocado por ejemplo el ciclo
menstrual por el estrés que deja esta
pandemia
si cada vez tenemos más y más reportes
no solamente de pacientes sino de la
población general que hablan de
trastornos en el ciclo menstrual esos
trastornos son o ciclos menstruales que
son que llega más rápido o que tardan
más en llegar o que no llega o que se
vuelven irregulares o que se pueden
acompañar de dolor también se ha visto
en pacientes con covid 19 que los
síntomas parecen fluctuar Con el ciclo y
cambien en la medida que va avanzando el
ciclo también se ha reportado pacientes
que ya estaban en menopausia y que
después del 19 volvieron a tener el
ciclo regularmente por ahora Estos son
reportes que tenemos
en términos de estudios científicos
todavía la evidencia es limitada
solamente tenemos un estudio en Turquía
que evaluó en la población general de
mujeres el impacto de la pandemia en los
cambios en los trastornos de los ciclos
menstruales y encontró que estos pasaron
del 12%
ahora afectar el 27% de la población
también muy interesante en este reporte
se evaluó la actividad sexual se observó
que las mujeres reportaban mayor
actividad sexual pero un descenso en la
calidad de la actividad sexual en fin es
un gran número de interrogantes Y
todavía mucha investigación que se
necesita para poder responderlos como
todo alrededor del Hobby 19 doctora Pero
además de las dificultades o las
diferencias y cambios que ha habido en
la llegada del periodo pues esto también
trae un acompañante preocupante y es un
posible balance o desbalance emocional
cómo sería esa gestión de emociones A
partir de los cambios físicos
Es un periodo tan difícil para todas las
personas que estamos viviendo la
pandemia afecta la ansiedad genera
estrés hemos visto reportes entre el 15
al 20% de la población general tiene
síntomas de estrés y densidad que son
patológicos Yo creo que es muy
importante establecer vínculos sociales
ya sea a través de internet compartir
las emociones seguir un estilo de vida
saludable hacer ejercicios seguir una
buena dieta controlar el sueño seguir
una rutinas muy claras de descanso son
muy importantes para poder manejar ese
estrés y esta ansiedad y si es demasiado
ya consultaron profesional doctor en
otras entrevistas con usted ya hemos
conversado sobre cómo el coronavirus
afecta más directamente a los hombres
que a las mujeres a lo largo de los
países algunas informaciones dejarían
entrever que la utilización de
estrógenos y de otras hormonas sexuales
podrían ayudar a luchar contra el
coronavirus esto es cierto
Así es desde el principio de la pandemia
vimos en China por ejemplo como dos
tercios de las personas que fallecían
eran hombres en Nueva York vimos dos
tercios de las personas que estaban en
cuidados intensivos eran hombres y
recientemente vimos un estudio publicado
en una revista importante por un grupo
en China un estudio multicéntrico en
Luján que evaluó unas 2.000 personas y
encuentra como los niveles de estrógenos
estaban asociados con una a mayor nivel
de estrógenos menor niveles de severidad
de la enfermedad también una menor
respuesta inflamatoria y una mejor
respuesta inmunitaria no solamente de la
inmunidad de las células que son los
linfocitos t sino también del desarrollo
de anticuerpos parece que estas células
tienen receptores para para los
estrógenos entonces todo esto ha
generado la teoría de que quizás si se
da estrógenos como suplemento podría
ayudar a mitigar el impacto que tiene el
19 de las personas entonces hay varios
ensayos clínicos en Nueva York en
California en los que se está
investigando por ejemplo como si se pone
estrógenos en parches Si eso podría
ayudar a mitigar el impacto del 19
doctor Muchas gracias como siempre un
placer tenerlo con nosotros y seguir
aclarando dudas sobre el 19 a nuestros
televidentes quédense con nosotros ya
volvemos con más en francés 24 buen día
[Música]